all right so a ton of you sent me news
articles and clips and audio of this
crazy anti-vaccine rally that took place
in new york city um i don't know i mean
listen i i understand that i think in
some sense it's surprising to some
people that this is going on in new york
city because new york city is such an
overwhelming liberal place but you know
it only takes a few crazies and in
particular based on the interviews i saw
some of these people were coming from
other states anyway there was some wacky
woman from pennsylvania saying she's
protesting against vaccines in new york
because she believes soon the mandates
are going to come to pennsylvania or
whatever the case may be
i'm going to play some of these clips
and
i i want to make sure everybody
understands
these are funny like it's okay to see
these as funny
and also recognize that because of it
the very unfunny reality of the
continued covet spread and possible
inability to ever get to herd immunity
in any real sense
um
may come as a result of the fact that
these people exist uh here's one woman
ranting
let's just look at these i think she has
a baby with her and it i can't tell if
it's a baby it is a baby okay it looked
maybe like it was a dog
um in a in a carrier no she has a baby
and she's here ranting about how
terrible vaccines are as we see
kids increasingly in icus with covid you
know i mean it's like this there's no
language that can even adequately
express the absurdity of this let's get
into the first clip here and you know
maybe get the kids out of the room these
clips are disturbing i cannot afford to
let my girls grow up in a world where
the government is allowed to force an
experimental injection into their bodies
i want to leave you with two thoughts
a usa chant drowning out the insane
anti-vaxx rhetoric what a country folks
[Applause]
okay yeah so um so that's that
uh i don't even really know where this
next clip kind of fits in this is more
about the tone than the substance or
more about the flavor than the
material or something like that um
they did the national anthem and this is
this is another just weird this is
really a cultural thing
where whether it's a blue state or a red
state they'll have an event for anything
it'll be a mike pillow rally it'll be an
anti-vaxx thing it'll be an anti-mask
protest out in a parking lot we covered
this out in the parking lot the
anti-mask protesters i think did both
the pledge of allegiance and the
national anthem so this is just watch
your ears watch your ears but this is
these are the sights and sounds of the
anti-vaxx rally
yeah and it keeps going really you know
you this is how you fight tyranny right
guys
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah
um
guys what do i even say about that right
i mean what um you know we have
i let's just move on to the next clip
okay i don't even know that the next one
necessarily needs any introduction let's
listen just as shirley and i love a sign
in here is discrimination based on race
gender age sexual orientation religion
and ethnicity have led to misery
policies that discriminate against the
unvaccinated will do the same thing
thank you
yeah so as you can tell there the the
idea is to analogize
that
discrimination by a business for example
on the basis of race is bad it's also
illegal or discrimination on the basis
of gender
or sexual orientation although
discriminating on the basis of sexual
orientation is legal in many states or
religion or ethnicity or whatever it's
the same as saying hey you gotta be
vaccinated to come in here because you
present the public health risk um being
black and going into a store doesn't
present a public health risk being gay
and going into a store doesn't present a
public health risk being unvaccinated
does and so the analogy is of course
uh terrible and by the way being
vaccinated or unvaccinated is a choice
now in a sense religion is also a choice
and we've talked about this before
should religion even be protected
as a class and
on the basis of it being a choice you
could make the case that it really
shouldn't
on the other hand there's the argument
that well it's such a a part of such a
core part
of what the united states is based on
it's a base based on freedom uh from
religion as well as freedom of religion
and you know i think
i'm not going around saying remove
religion
but you can make the case that what
we're really trying to focus on here is
not discriminating on the basis of
immutable conditions things that are
just who you are
and choosing not to get vaccinated is
not an immutable characteristic and so
the analogy is completely wrong
last clip here this is sort of a medley
this was put together by the recount
it's really good um all of these clips
are actually from the recount twitter
account which has done a really good job
covering this stuff this is a medley of
the anti-vaxx rally in new york city
take a look at this this is anti-vaxx
rally to force an experimental injection
into their body they're not vaccines
they're poisoned a vaccine this isn't a
vaccine this is some kind of a bio
pharma
injection
[Laughter]
well uh
it is an injection it was made by pharma
i guess the the prefix bio applies
uh i think we're maybe
talking about a distinction without a
difference there that that's maybe my
favorite moment here's another guy this
is uh a sort of a keanu reeves type guy
saying something very very important
ramirez i am a socialist proudly
you don't get many of those in this
movement
yeah so people booing the socialism but
cheering for the anti-vaxx now that's
that's actually a really interesting
thing to talk about
um
for
i think for eight years on this show for
a while we've covered other anti-vaxx
movements there's never been anything
like with the coveted vaccine but for
example the measles anti-vaxx movement
we've covered and i've explained and
we've looked at
this phenomenon where
you see these anti-measles vax enclaves
in really red areas and in really blue
areas and the reason is that left-wing
anti-vax and right-wing anti-vax have
kind of been pulled together
for different reasons the right-wing
anti-vaxxers
don't want the government being involved
in public health campaigns and vaccine
requirements and vaccinations okay
the left-wing anti-vacs are skeptical of
big pharma because they're skeptical of
lots of types of corporations and they
end up together and that's super
interesting where these really are
strange bedfellows let's look at that
again this is an anti-vaxx socialist who
says i am i am here uh and i am
anti-vaxx and he actually gets booed for
at least initially my name is garrett
ramirez i am a socialist proudly
you don't get many of those in this
movement
discrimination based on race
gender age policies that discriminate
against the unvaccinated will do the
same thing this is a trick to get us to
have digital ids and they don't know
science but they know marketing
[Applause]
[ __ ] are not gonna force me
now that's wrong it's sons of [ __ ]
it's like attorneys general it's not son
of a [ __ ] unless you have i guess
multiple moms i don't know anyway that's
a very technical analysis there um this
is delusional this is really dangerous
of course and um
politics makes very strange
bedfellows and all we can hope for is
that the public health campaigns and the
vaccine requirements that are being put
in place make it just much easier to go
and get vaccinated than to do anything
else um and i still maintain that if er
we'll talk by the way about delta
airlines and vaccinations on the bonus
show today
i still think that one of the ways to
most quickly get more people interested
in vaccines
is for airlines to require them in order
to fly maybe an issue we will take take
up again in the future
one of our sponsors is rise the science
based app that makes it easy to improve
your sleep and daily energy i have
struggled with sleep at times in my life
i've tried many different things and
rise has been really useful
it tracks your sleep debt which is how
much sleep you essentially owe your body
tracks your general rhythms helps you
understand your daytime energy levels
and rise can improve your sleep and
energy by giving you personalized
feedback about your sleep metrics when
you should go to bed when you should
wake up in terms of optimizing your
personal rest it can even tell you
things like how long should you expect
to be groggy in the morning based on
when you wake up you can make
science-based improvements to 16
different habits that will make you feel
more rested every day and most rise
users start feeling that way in the
first five days including me and ryze is
still helping me every day it's great
it's based on real sleep science
very few things are as important as
improving your sleep go to rise science
dot com slash pacman to try rise free
for a week the link is underneath this
video